hi there Steve Kaufman here today I
would like to talk about why I think so
many people have trouble learning
languages now many of you have heard me
say before that the three keys to
language learning our motivation the
time you spend with the language not
necessarily in class but with the
language listening reading talking and
the third thing is the ability to notice
what's happening in the language which
is a skill that we acquire the more time
we spend learning languages so someone
who isn't motivated and isn't going to
spend the time they're not going to
learn they won't develop the ability to
notice that's fine but there are many
people who are motivated who do spend
the time but don't succeed and why is
that they sort of abandon in frustration
so I've given this quite a bit of
thought because ideally like I Here I am
at age 67 I'm having my great time
learning languages communicating with
people in different languages and body
health you know the goal of learning
even more languages and I'm having a
blast again and yet then I hear from
people who are learning their first
language others for second language and
are completely frustrated what is the
what is the problem well I think that
one major issue is that people who
haven't learned a second language who
have never become fluent in a second
language don't believe they can do it
they've never done it before they've
never experienced it before so it's a
it's a bit like trying to climb a
mountain if you don't believe you're
going to reach the top of the mountain
so I think that is one of the major
reasons people just haven't done it
before so they don't have the confidence
that they can do it they don't know how
to do it there are a lot of things about
language learning they don't realize
they don't realize that you're going to
forget what you learn you have to keep
learning it and forgetting it and
learning it and
that should not be a cause for
frustration people get frustrated if
they make mistakes people get frustrated
if they didn't learn that lesson and
nail it down but it's impossible to do
that and these are things that I tell
people but they don't accept they seem
to feel that if they put all that effort
into learning and memorizing that
somehow these things should stick with
them that they should be understand that
they should be able to use these words
that they should be able to get their
tenses right and of course you can't so
I think people who have experience with
learning languages are used to the idea
that it's a gradual process of getting
used to the language people who haven't
ah they want to see results they want to
be able to say something and they won't
be able to say it correctly maybe it's
our school system that makes us thinking
along these lines that because we study
something we should learn it and maybe
there are things you know if you're
studying for a test in physics you've
got to try to remember those things for
the test and you have to try to
understand the concept and so forth
whereas language is different even if
you understand the concept you still
won't be able to necessarily use it
correctly and you won't understand it
when you listen time and time again so I
think this is a very important concept
that language is a matter of getting
used to and and this is this is really
an approach to learning which is in some
ways quite oriental even though in in
places like Japan and China and Korea
they're very much into the sort of the
teacher the professor the master will
teach me in fact if we look at their
traditions if we look at sort of the Zen
tradition if we look at you know drums
in in Chinese philosophy if we look at
some of the approaches to craftsmanship
in Japan it's very much a matter of
watching people and learning and not a
as they say in Japanese getting used to
something it's not learning it
theoretically from a book it's gradually
getting used to it that it sort of
layers on to you and with each layer
certain things become clearer and
these things become clear some other
things become clear but you have to have
the confidence that this process this
layering process is exposing yourself to
the language is going to lead to your
desired result because if you don't have
that confidence then I guess it can be a
frustrating experience and so I think
the question that is someone who hasn't
had the experience of learning a
language if that's the obstacle how do
you overcome it it's kind of like a
catch-22 you can't achieve that sense of
transforming yourself into someone who
can become fluent in another language
until you do it so you kind of have to
have that leap of faith you can do it
anyone can do it now granted the more
languages you learn as in my case I've
learned a number of languages so that
not only have I gotten used to different
languages I've gotten used to to
learning out develop might exceed
techniques of learning and people who
have learned a number of languages
therefore have become accustomed to the
process have developed their own
techniques and so forth and so on so
what do you do with that beginner
learner the first purse the first
language the person is learning their
first new language well you know a it's
a matter of having confidence that you
can do it because others have done it
others in different countries different
cultural backgrounds different ages it's
not a matter of having some unique
talent because if you go to Sweden they
all do it they don't all have some
special gene anyone can do it at
whatever age all right so you have to
accept that and I think the other thing
is to do things that are enjoyable so
that that the frustration of forgetting
the first frustration of making mistakes
the frustration of feeling that you're
very clumsy when you speak that those
things don't become the dominant
experience you have to do things that
are enjoyable so that the enjoyable
aspect of language learning becomes the
dominant experience so that you put in
the time that you get enough exposure
that you
cost them to the language what are those
enjoyable experiences that depends on
each person for me as I've said many
times it's listening to things of
interest
it's discovering Romania to Radio
Romania discovering Czech history
through Doki Jessica University or
discovering Russia through FM speed
reading about it reading about the
history of the countries or that to me
is enjoyable other people want to get
out and speak early fine but you know
and and I don't for example do grammar
exercises because I don't find them
enjoyable some people may find them
enjoyable if you can focus on doing
things that you enjoy so that the
journey itself is enjoyable if you can
accept the fact that implied in language
learning is forgetting is making
mistakes is being clumsy is not
understanding and that it's just the
process of exposing yourself rather than
trying to nail down a table of
declension of endings or conjugations
but rather that that if you spend the
time with the language gradually your
brain will get used to it and your
ability to notice things will improve in
my sort of trichotomy there of
motivation everyone understands that yes
motivation you gotta like the language
you gotta even you know determined
you've got to think you can do it you
can't resist the language the people
understand that spend the time they
understand you got to spend an hour to a
day that everyone understands but
learning to notice people don't you
understand but I hadn't happened to me
so many times that I don't notice
certain things in the language that I
don't know how to pick I always use the
example well take the third-person
singular in the present tense in English
people are told you have an S theorist I
go you go he goes people say yeah I
understand that and then they kind of
don't really pay attention when they
hear the language or the pronunciation
I'll use the example many times of
people who rely on how words are
pronounced or how certain Spelling's are
pronounced in their own language so word
becomes whoa
they aren't listening they aren't paying
attention they aren't noticing and so
the more you learn languages the more
you learn of a particular language the
more experience you have with a language
you start to notice better these are all
forms of experience that you gradually
accumulate you gradually accumulate so a
lot of people experience frustration and
language learning because they have
never achieved success in language
learning
but success breeds success and once
you've done it once and you realize that
objective of becoming fluent in another
language and you realize how wonderful
it is to do that then you have the
confidence that you can that you can do
it again success breeds success
some people stay within the comfort of
certain language families Latin you know
Romance languages or European languages
but I think the same applies to learning
a language from a completely different
language group say Chinese or Japanese
or Arabic first people are again
intimidated because they haven't done it
before but once they do it and they've
achieved that sense of success then they
know they can do it so I guess that the
message here is for those of you who do
experience frustration in your language
learning you have to stay the course
find ways to enjoy it find some way to
climb that first mountain once you have
climbed that first mountain then you
look out and you see all the other peaks
and you know that you can climb any of
those other peaks because you've already
done it
the hardest one is the first one so I
hope that that is in some way motivate I
should say one more thing by the way
I've made a lot of videos now in English
if you would like to hear a video in
another language please let me know but
I want to do these four speakers of
those languages I don't want to just
sort of demonstrate Romanian or
something if someone feels that they are
following me in English but don't fully
understand and would like to hear it in
Japanese or French or or Spanish or
Portuguese or some other language please
let me know and I will make mistakes
when I do these in other languages
perhaps fewer mistakes and French or
Japanese and many mister
akes and Russian or Portuguese but I'm
happy to do them with mistakes because
if I say that it's important to accept
the fact that we make mistakes when we
speak foreign languages I have to accept
the fact that I'm going to make mistakes
and I don't mind showing my mistakes to
other people it's all part of the
process so I look forward to hearing
from you you can ask me here or you can
simply can send a message via Twitter
however you want
lingo Steve and I'd be happy to answer
your questions
or if you have a special request to hear
some of this my views on language
learning in other languages please let
me know thank you for listening bye for
now